what's up good humans milky here before
we dive in we want to take a second to
thank eme high for partnering with us
for this video ama hive is the number
one asian live streaming and dating app
where you can share your life with new
friends or get serious with dating it's
a one-stop shop for dating mingling and
entertainment i personally love a good
dating app but sometimes men scare me
the cool thing about eme hive is that
it's a genuine way to meet and chat with
real people via video so i know i'm
making real connections and not being
catfished by mean teenagers there are 24
7 endless live streams karaoke mystery
gift games and live battles so it's the
perfect place to find and connect with
people this dating site has successfully
created happy passionate and fulfilling
relationships they've already helped 150
000 people find partners so far and they
have over 1.4 million users around the
world by successfully matching couples
with mutual backgrounds and interests
eme hype is the number one premium asian
dating site you can find the right
person for you with ems advanced
matching algorithm or filters like
ethnicities high education interests and
even the age they arrived in the us
hey
anyone want a date be sure to check out
emehive using our link in the
description below now let's get into the
video
[Music]
wow
that's a good reaction
[Music]
hi i am leighton higuard i'm from
minneapolis i make music i do
environmental science and i am a model
personally i mean i know i'm like i'm
really slender and a lot of that is due
to a medical condition that i had in
this past year so i got really sick and
i lost about 25 pounds i think i mean
i'm definitely kind of self-conscious
because i mean it changed a lot i think
personality is much more important than
body type i mean obviously it helps if
you're attracted to someone and
you think
that they look good
i'm really ready to see some bodies
wow nice
feet
10 out of 10.
wow okay contestant one
let's see you have some marks on your
toenails what's that from
from me dropping like tools and other
random crap okay i like the woodwork and
stuff so so you like hit your feet a
couple of times that's uh more than a
couple that sounds painful solid solid
feet okay love that thank you okay
contestant two um hello
feet as well looking
great um you have a couple marks on one
of your toes did something happen
she's investigating
yeah i'm investigating there's not much
i can go on i recently got a pedicure
and i had
some color put on oh
it was the effort of me trying to take
the color off without going back
um contestant three okay a little dance
yeah
um love that
looks like you cut your toenails like
very sharp
yeah i am i am i am trash at cutting my
toenails that looks like that would like
hurt really bad if someone like scraped
them what happened i just am crap at
cutting my own toenails
okay okay um a little scary but good
okay
contestant for okay i love the little
oh shy a little shy foot tell me about
the toenails uh um they match my hands
so on one hand it's like short and then
the other one's long because i play
guitar so it looked weird i love only
having like not matching your sets you
know yeah you just got to be
coordinating yeah it's like having like
not matching underwear and bra it's i
just went
with the full set on you well
unfortunately i'm not matching
that's a
contestant five hello you have big feet
um i think you know what they say
big socks let's see what do you do
they're actually no marks or anything
so what do you do for work uh work i'm
trying to become a registered nurse but
right now i'm a certified nurse
assistant in a hospital
oh so i don't really drop tools on my
feet last but not least i love the
little toe dances people are doing at
the ends you have long feet yes yeah
that's what they say
you get that a lot
do people say that a lot to you
you should see it from this angle i oh
well wait wait that would that wasn't
meant to be anyways
yeah i cut them for you wow thank you so
much for that
i'm gonna eliminate contestant
three
just because of the toenails what i
thought we'd at least make it to my
underwear first you know i wore the
narwhal ones just for you yeah oh my god
i am i love the narwhals you missed out
you missed that i miss out i am so sorry
it's okay you know it's all right it's
great to meet you thanks mr narwhal i've
never judged someone based on
feet i'm glad people have feet
shout out to walking
wow
all right
love it that's that's a good reaction
number three's
scared looking
whoa the toes are like together this is
so weird
okay oh underwear oh on the side profile
huh
okay
i'd say
number two
okay do you guys have like a preferred
body type in
your partner and also like how do you
feel about your own body as well i would
probably prefer an athletic body type um
simply because i like to do a lot of
various activities i'm confident in my
body i care more about what it can do
and not what it really looks like it's
good good answer love that how do you
take care of your body
how do i take care of my body i love
this i feel like i'm in a commercial i
eat
well i think what do you eat my favorite
food is thai food okay contestant too
the body type i'm attracted to is a more
curvy type it's important to have that
attraction up front and then personality
matters a lot more after that i'm very
confident with my body i just don't
really care what other people think of
my body because i like my body like
however it is and question for you
um what's your
favorite body part on a guy
my favorite body part on a guy
probably eyes because they say i feel
like you just can tell so much about a
person from their eyes i used to
actually be like a lot more fit like
maybe like 25 pounds heavier because i
used to
wrestle for like the junior olympic team
and now i just like
sing songs and draw on people so i'm
like way skinnier and i had to get
comfortable with like
this like
the change in my own body so i don't
really have a preference in body type
like as long as
um like let's say you just care for
yourself or like you care about how you
look or like you try to stay healthy
like that's all that matters to me like
as long as you're confident your own
body i don't really go to like the gym
but i mean if my friends want to go like
i'll go with them i'm confident my body
like i i played basketball growing up
you know ever since i was a little kid
and i got into working out around
seventh grade and like strength and
conditioning training so you can tell um
yeah
i definitely need a girl that's shorter
than me um
but you know i i really don't have like
two specific preferences i think the
face matters the most you mentioned
something about
uh you lost 25 pounds
yeah um good question i had a medical
mess up like some doctors kind of
medically messed up on me with some
medication basically i was in the icu
about a month and a half ago
i
got off the medication and got better so
nice
yeah i guess that's i'm glad you're
feeling better thank you yeah cheers to
being alive
okay everyone was great it's hard to
eliminate i guess i'm gonna do number
one
[Music]
i hi
super nice to meet you thank you
love that we're meeting this way hello
it's freezing you have a really nice
petite body it's lovely
yeah you have a good body too
thank you
i think
number three
with the best feet though hey hello nice
to meet you nice to meet you i'll give
you a hug okay i'm cold oh that is cold
i'm all gone
nice
and scene
um
love it
all right so i'm gonna ask you guys to
all do a little dance move
all right
oh
wow
solid solid
like a quick little pop and then
jump back into it
everybody should do that when they meet
someone
tap dance wait what
am i gonna do ballet
do your tattoos have meetings this
tattoo
is a sunflower with just some plants
around it
it's not too deep but sunflowers are my
favorite flower and every time i look at
them they just
make me feel happy so just like a
reminder to myself to just
be happy and always strive to be happy
in life
you have a lot of tattoos um
i know it's your job what inspired you
to get into it the white one's so cool
yeah so it's like how does that work
yeah you just do white ink instead of
black ink uh my first tattoo is on my
hand i get them when i travel so like a
travel log so like they're all from
different places on my arms and legs and
back it's like a travel log i think
that's awesome that you like have those
memories with you okay number three no
tattoos yeah no tattoos i'm sorry that's
okay i don't have tattoos either asian
parents they don't allow it but you know
maybe one day solid
legs
um
body you look super fit you look strong
which is always
a plus too what would you guys do to
comfort me if i was really sad
one thing that i like to do when i'm sad
is
create actionable steps as to like how
to feel better um like for example clean
your room or i don't know things that
make you feel good so i definitely
like huddle you and listen to you and um
i try to like make you feel more
comfortable i'd probably just like be
there listen and maybe hold on on the
device until later like all the emotions
are flooded through and then later like
come back to it
everyone's so nice that's hard this
sucks um i think i'm gonna eliminate
number one
[Music]
yeah just because
i don't know
there's there's like no specific reason
[Music]
i just thought the other ones like were
funnier i guess and not in a bad way you
were also
really funny too great body
you have a great body too you're really
pretty too oh thank you
okay i think i'm gonna eliminate number
one
close though
yeah i forgot sorry
i got eliminated
i love
everything about
your story
your body is like literally a story
[Music]
hi
nice to meet you i'm leighton good nice
to meet you i'm scott nice to see you
outside of the yeah yeah i guess uh i
guess we're going to go on a picnic day
and if it goes well we're getting
matching tattoos i think that's the move
right yeah we're both going to get
tested for the first time what do you
think of each other seeing each other
now i mean i think you're beautiful
score thank you so much yeah no you look
great too it's so weird basing
everything off i mean everyone i think
looks great
are you gonna put yours in here yes
cool i'll follow you back maybe nah
i love that you're just like maybe not
awesome oh you're popular
[ __ ] dude 76k followers
thanks man
that changed all right
no i'm just kidding yeah i got a measly
measly 2k